if there's a silver lining to the
pandemic it's the
increase in innovation we've seen it in
people businesses
and non-profits all trying to survive
opportunity village for example
is starting a new business it's in a
field they're pretty familiar with
hector mejia is live to tell us all
about it and hector
i think i smell a good idea tell us more
i think you do hey there sherry good
morning and it all officially launches
tomorrow
on national cookie day so there's a clue
right there opportunity village is now
making cookies at a mass scale baking
them
out of their campus here in the
southwest valley
i'm delighted to invite you to
participate
in opportunity village's newest and
sweetest venture ever
dasy's table
and there it is opportunity village has
ventured into mass producing cookies
the non-profit provides programs and
jobs for adults
with intellectual disabilities and
they're producing what they are calling
premium cookie pucks
depending on the type of business or
need it is
new because we are mass producing it
working
you know we're hoping to be with
businesses we've already got a lot of
great response from the community and
you can pick up frozen cookie books to
bake to serve at home or you can
purchase that you know
20 000 at a time to you know provide for
a business
now listen to this they can make a
hundred frozen cookie pucks
per minute so in a day that adds up to
twenty to thirty
thousand and they're trying to survive
the pandemic like all of us
the pandemic forced opportunity village
to cancel magical forest the big
fundraiser would generate millions of
dollars and pays for the community
programs
and they hoped to make it into grocery
stores convenience stores and become a
household name and eventually they told
us
they plan to make other baked goods
reporting live in the southwest valley
this morning hector mejia
8 news dan i think i've had some of
their baked goods before hector they're
pretty tasty creations there thank you
sir